[Music]
thank you so much Peter to swix to all
of the AI engineer Summit for having me
I am so thrilled to be here I'm Grace
again a partner at Lux capital and it's
a pleasure to really kick off this
conference and tackle a pretty tough but
exciting task the state of the AI
Frontier and how we navigate that in
2025 so a little bit about Lux as we get
started here right Lux likes to say we
believe before others understand we
invest in Frontier Tech ideas that seem
crazy right uh and we really like to
bring sci-fi to SCI fact in fact we've
been lucky to partner at the earliest
stages with some top AI companies
hugging face I'm sure several folks know
it the GitHub for machine learning
together AI The open- Source AI Cloud
physical intelligence that's like a
robotics software brain and S AI That's
a research lab actually in Tokyo Japan
doing really cool evolutionary nature
inspired algorithms they just launched a
pretty cool AI Cuda scientist last night
so go check it out moving a little bit
forward as we think about New York City
I get my clicker working
here there we go Lu is really excited to
double down in New York City and AI Lux
was founded in New York City our first
AI investment was here in 2013 and a
majority of the Lux AI portfolio is
actually headquartered here or as a
major Hub as you can kind of see in the
graph behind me it's also home to many
of you right state-of-the-art research
and Engineering leaders and many 4 500
companies several of whom you're going
to hear from over the next few days we
are really bullish on the New York City
opportunity and we're really excited you
guys all came to share this opportunity
with
us so when I was creating this
presentation I went back and looked at
the last few years of AI right and all
the way back really to stable diffusion
August 2022 and wow I mean look at this
hockey stick right the last two and a
half years have been crazy the last 18
months have been even more exponential
the progress is getting more aggressive
it's getting more impressive and really
it's getting more spread right it's not
just open Ai and anthropics publishing
these models it's xai we just saw the
grock launch this past week it's mistal
it's deep seek it's many many more and
the models are getting more performant
they're also getting more compute
efficient and as we zoom in to the
current state of the world in
2025 it's off to an even Wilder start
right if you thought the last few years
were crazy 2025 is even Wilder we saw
the 500 billion Stargate project
announced between the US government open
AI soft bank and Oracle we saw 03 open
eyes 03 right before the start of the
Year where they actually exceeded C
performance and the arc AGI challenge we
saw the Deep seek Mania right with deep
seeks R1 model launching earlier this
year sending you know Nvidia shares
tumbling down we also saw deep SE go to
number one uh in the app store and then
of course just last week we saw the
France AI Summit where macron actually
launched a whole new AI initiative with
France and Europe back in the
game so you may be saying and I think a
lot of us are thinking right this is the
AI agent moment in 2025 and I'd go as
far as say this is the perfect storm for
for AI agents and frankly it's easy to
see why right uh several reasoning
models starting with open a eyes 01 then
03 deep sees R1 grock's latest reasoning
model this past week are outperforming
human ability and in some cases even
having more capabilities that we've
never even seen before we've seen the
rise of test time compute right that's
more compute appi at INF frence instead
of at training that's increasing this
model performance as well we' seen
further engineering and harder
optimizations right whatever you think
it cost to actually train that deep seek
model you cannot deny it was a feat of
engineering and Hardware efficiency
inference is getting cheaper Hardware is
getting cheaper the open source close
Source Gap is getting Clos closed
between deep seek and llama models
getting more and more performant and of
course billions of infrastructure
powering all this data center and
compute we just talked about the US
Stargate we talked about macron and
Europe and also Japan with sopig and
Nvidia has been doubling down on their
data set of efforts so all this is
setting this exciting groundwork for the
aonomus name of our conference agents at
work and it really does feel like an
exciting
moment but in reality these AI agents
aren't really working just yet right
people are saying it's a perfect storm
and I'm seen a lot of Thunder I'm seen a
lot of great momentum but we haven't
seen that lightning strike uh and
everyone I know has different definition
of Agents so for the purposes of this
presentation I'm going to Define my
definition as an AI agent that is a
fully autonomous system where llms
direct their own
actions so let's give a little example
of what I mean when I say an AI agent
isn't working just yet here's a
seemingly simple query on open a ey
operator I'm sure everyone here knows
what it is I asked it to book a flight
for me to New York to San Francisco on
Monday I'm sure it's also a route and
something that many people in this room
are familiar with and in reality it's
actually kind of a complex problem right
I need to leave after 3 on Monday but I
want to avoid rush hour traffic I want
to fly United JetBlue or American to
maximize my chance of an upgrade from
economy I want to keep it under $500 to
keep under my work expense policy I also
want to aisle seat that's not too close
to the bathroom um and I want to get
there you know before midnight so I put
this in to open AI
operator and the first thing it did with
all this information is go to kayak
which if anyone has booked a flight
before that's a pretty frustrating
experience and unfortunately it did not
find a flight uh it wasn't able um it
couldn't find one it didn't even seem to
look for United or American second try
try it again uh this is Skys scanner
this time which is slightly better um
and it did actually find a flight but it
found one that had a lot of traffic uh
5:30 JFK for those who live in New York
that is a tough traffic time um and
ultimately I also couldn't even pick my
seat so didn't really work out based on
my prompts uh
earlier so what does this all mean right
why these AI agents not work I think we
so often talk about hallucinations and
fabrications and AI models kind of going
sideways we don't talk enough about
these tiny cumulative errors that add up
right uh there's a lot of little that we
see with this old model and I'm going to
go through a few it's not an exhaustive
list but it's a sense of some of the
things you might run into as you're
building these AI agents first decision
error it chooses the wrong fact right I
may book a flight with AI but it may
book it to San Francisco Peru instead of
San Francisco
California the model could overthink or
exaggerate and do a few other things as
well second implementation error the
wrong access or integration on the prior
slide with my Skys scanner I actually
had to enter capture and that messed up
a little bit of the flow you also could
get locked out of a critical access to
an important database and ultimately
that AI agent isn't going to work
anymore third heuristic error the wrong
criteria unfortunately the model didn't
acknowledge best practice of allowing
enough time for JFK in fact I didn't
even ask where I was coming from
Manhattan Brooklyn or Beyond and that
could really affect the traffic you're
going to get and ultimately if I even
make that at 5:30 p.m. and fourth taste
error the wrong personal preferences for
those who know me well I'm actually a
pretty spooked flyer and I do not like
flying Boeing 737 Maxes if AI booked
that you know I did not put it in the
prompt earlier but if it did book that I
will be very unhappy and I would not get
on that
plane and then there's kind of a fifth
more nebulous error right it's a little
bit of this Perfection Paradox right we
are doing things so magical with AI
right now yet we're getting frustrated
when o1 thinks too long or when operator
moves at the speed of a
human even if the agent gets it right on
the first try often they're inconsistent
and unreliable leading to really
underwhelming our human expectations
about the whole
experience here's another visual of kind
of these complex systems where each of
these cumulative errors really compound
right two simple agents one that's 99%
accuracy one that's 95% accuracy to
start pretty impressive agents at the
beginning but over 50 consecutive steps
you actually realize a pretty big
disparity here there's actually a 50%
difference after 50 tasks between the 95
and the 99 and that 99% agents actually
down to 60% the point here is that
something simple like booking a flight
is actually really complex in nature
when all these tiny cumulative errors
add up and they get even more Amplified
in a complex multi-agent system with
multi-step
tasks so how do you as all these amazing
VPS of AI these leaders of AI in the
room optimize a complex agent taking
into account all of these really
difficult queries to consistently and
reliably make the right
decision the truth
is it's
hard but that hasn't stopped us before
and there is hope so I thought I would
run through some of the best practices
that we're seeing building AI agents
today and five strategies
we can all think about to help mitigate
a lot of these cumulative errors let's
Dive In First Data curation how do we
make sure an AI agent has the
information it needs data is messy it's
unstructured it's in silos it's
everywhere it's not just web and text
data now too it's design data it's image
data it's video data it's audio data
it's a data in your sensors and your
Warehouse if you're in the manufacturing
world it's even the agent data that your
data your agent is producing in real
real time think about curating
proprietary data the data the AI agent
generates and ultimately even the data
you're using in your model workflow for
Quality Control Data is your best asset
and curation is key to making it more
effective data also isn't static anymore
how do you design an agent data flywheel
from day one so every time a user uses
the product it automatically improves in
real time and at scale
a simple example back to our flight
example is getting a curated data set of
all of Grace's travel preferences
including the 737 Max and all my Airline
preferences or even say we run that
agent over time and book many flights
how do we recycle back that content and
adapt to my own preferences in real time
second the importance of evals how do we
collect and measure a model's response
how do we choose the correct answer this
is long but important in machine
learning and Ai and really understanding
what's right versus wrong you know it's
pretty simple in verifiable domains
where there's a clear yes or no answer
like math like science here's actually
the grock three benchmarks just up here
where you saw they did all verifiable
benchmarks in math and sciences but how
do we set up evaluations for
non-verifiable systems where there
aren't clear yes or no answers like well
Grace like this plan seat based on her
preferences and how do we collect those
signals
too we also saw another examples of an
eval debate over the weekend with deep
research right we have an open ey deep
research product one from perplexity one
from Gemini as well and there are
multiple versions of the same product
The evals here really depend on the eye
of the beholder right which one is
better for everyday research versus VC
market research versus scientific or
academic research we have to keep an eye
on collecting those signals we need to
know and collect human preferences and
we need to build evals in a way that is
truly
personal Sometimes the best eval is just
trying out the agent yourself and Vibes
based on your needs with no number or
leaderboard telling you what to
do third Scaffolding Systems how do we
ensure when one error occurs it doesn't
have a cascading effect throughout the
organization ramp a portfolio company
has done a great job with this and I
know Rahul is speaking tomorrow so go
check him out when ramp launches a new
applied AI feature and it fails there's
infrastructure logic to ensure that
doesn't have a cascading effect across
the agentic system and also across all
of ramp production infrastructure we can
mitigate scaffolding by building a
complex compound system of how all these
things work together and sometimes even
bringing a human back in the loop for
reasoning models get this gets even more
interesting and important how do we
adapt the scaffold to Stronger agents
that self-heal and grow an agent that
realizes they're wrong and actually
tries to correct their own path or an
agent that's not sure and then needs
bring break execution to get it back on
track back to our travel example again
could we add a checkpoint for this AI
agent to verify the Trine for traffic or
maybe steer it back in the right
direction fourth user experience or ux
is the m that matters and that's how our
AI agents become better co-pilots AI
apps today are all using the same models
Foundation models are the fastest
depreciating asset class on the market
right now gbt rappers are cool ux really
does make a difference for those who
reimagine product experiences and really
deeply understand the user workflow and
really promote that beautiful elegant
human machine collaboration right here's
a few concrete examples back to the Deep
research right asking clarifying
questions to make sure it fully got the
picture of what I'm trying to accomplish
like Wier from codium understanding the
ux or the psyche of that developer
really on a more fundamental level to
predict their next step like Harvey in
the legal World integrating seamlessly
with the Legacy systems to really create
real Roi for a practicing
lawyer if you think about all the major
AI apps today and categories like coding
like customer support like sales these
all are using the same models again
right and it's truly the ux and the
product quality that makes any one
company stand out at Lux we're really
excited about the new AI Frontier
companies who have proprietary data
sources and who know the workflow flow
of their user really well like robotics
like Hardware like defense and
Manufacturing like the life sciences you
know how do we take a company where they
take their proprietary data source they
know the workflow of a biologist or a
defense contractor or a chemist and
truly create a magical experience for
that end
user Fifth and finally how do we build
multimodally you know we're not just
multimodal anymore we're
multimodal there's new modalities where
we can Tru reimagine and create a 10x
user personalized experience I am so
sick and tired of the chatbot as an
interface and I know there's so many
more exciting things we can do with our
AI agents to really make them more human
right how do we make AI more human how
do we add eyes and ears nose a voice
we've seen really incredible
improvements in voice over the last year
it's getting pretty scary good Lux
actually has an investment in the smell
space called osmo that's digitizing the
sense of smell
and what about touch right how do we
instill a more human feeling and sense
of embodiment with
robotics I'll go as far to even talk
about memories right how do we make AI
truly personal and know you on a much
deeper level than it does
today doing all of this reframes what
Perfection is to a human and even if
that agent is inconsistent it's
unreliable the Visionary nature of the
product exceeds all expectations it's
something new and on the slide behind me
you'll see tlop that's an amazing Lux
portfolio company and I think they've
done a great job really reimagining the
visual canvas right implementing AI
through breast Strokes they have a cool
thing called he jaw computer where you
can actually combine a bunch of these
cool AI models in Tandem and not even
know you're working with a large
language model in the background so
really strive to build
multimodally so in summary we tackled a
lot today but we're at the perfect storm
today for AI agents but unfortunately
that lightning hasn't struck yet and AI
agents are not going to happen
overnight cumulative errors add up we
see wrong answers wrong preferences
wrong criteria all these wrong human
expectations that abound when you're
building these systems data curation
evals and Scaffolding are all tools you
can use to help mitigate a lot of these
challenges and really please think
bigger ux multimodality Innovative
product experience that truly set the
workflow and the vision apart and I'm so
excited to see what all of you build and
really excited to this conversation over
the next few days thank you guys so much
and look forward to talking to you
throughout the conference thank you
[Music]